Hey, some folks out there got  a little upset after the election.
They're a little bit freaked out.
Some of them are a lot freaked out
Some of you are waaay too sucked into that vortex, I will just tell you.
Uhm... but hey! Here's an idea.
Try to find somebody and be nice to him today
Some people are really thinking things are gonna to be worse than they are.
And they are freaking out, man.
I mean, the fear is amazing out there among some of the Hillary followers.
So, uhm, some of you think stuff is gonna happen that's not going to happen.
It 'cause you're young and you haven't lived through this before. It's okay.
It's gonna be alright.
It really is. You're gonna be alright.
And, uhm, the world is not coming to an end.
And the world would not come to an end if it's the other way around.
If the other... If the other... Hillary had won.
So, you're gonna be alright. And, you know, here's what you need to do.
You need to concentrate on your life and you need to be careful what you're putting into your brain.
I mean, watching these news channels just day in and day out.
Every little nuance. Every little nasty thing in the whole election cycle.
It's just enough to destroy your spirit.
And you really, really need to get away from that.
You just live your life mad 'cause you're watching stuff all the time.
And, uhm, whether you're left, whether you're right.
You just spend all your time being mad. Life is too short, man. Really. Seriously.